surprise de ce mondial dans les mois qui
ont précédé les allergiques au football
nous avait prédit une augmentation des
scènes de ménage voir des divorces
pendant la compétition et bien on s'est
aperçu que parmi les téléspectateurs de
la coupe du monde il y avait plus de 30%
de femmes
à commencer bien entendu par les
premiers intéressés les épouses
respectives des joueurs de l'équipe de
france sophie mével jean-paul chausset
petite ambiance en cette fin d'après
midi devant le siège de la fédération
française de football avenue d'iéna à
paris une poignée de supporteurs qui
semble égarée
et pourtant non ceux là savent que c'est
ici comme avant chaque match que les
femmes et sciences et de joueurs se
donnent rendez-vous pour partir ensemble
au stade de france acclamer leurs héros
frédéric gary ivagnas lama et claude
deschamps respecte le mot d'ordre de la
fédération
la discrétion pas un mot ne filtre de ce
côté là bonjour bonjour vous allez bien
alors c'est bon ça va ça va bien à
l'approché du match vous aurez également
plus bas on peut penser que la pression
mais ça va aller se marier téléphone ou
quand il a la pression c'est forcément
mieux
ouais
ça ne dit pas vous avez eu votre mari
est allé vite bien salaires que vouliez
vous souhaitez la con courage c'est le
déclic grille il a quelque chose à vous
sur lui pendant le match quelques jolis
je pense qu'ils ont le droit cette sa
fille au poignet au poignet
éventuellement côté une question miss
karembeu adriana est aussi connu pour
son record personnel une longueur de
jean faramineuses un maître 24 c'est
toujours le même rituel vous savez moi
je lui souhaite bonne chance et lui il
me répond tout va bien on va gagner ce
soir après le match
on leur a tout premier quelques
précieuses minutes d'intimité avec l'as
rome
cette seule idée devrait amener ces
messieurs souhaitons le à se dépasser